In Venezuela, cars don’t depreciate.
You could buy one today, drive it for five
or six years, and then sell it for the same
price you paid.
And you can forget about gas.
At just over six cents a gallon, you can fill
up your tank for less than one U.S. Dollar.
In Venezuela, banks offer loans for plastic
surgery.
Taxi drivers earn higher salaries than doctors.
Supermarkets are equipped with fingerprint
scanners.
And some find it cheaper to live year-round
in luxury hotels than rent an apartment.
Sponsored by Brilliant.
Learn math, science, and computer science
the intuitive way with the link in the description.
In 2015, the country with the largest proven
oil reserves on earth — enough to meet all
of America’s demand for forty years — ran
out of toilet paper.
Hotels even asked guests to bring their own.
Facing shortages of rice, sugar, milk, and
shampoo, on top of rolling blackouts, 30 million
people struggled to survive without the most
basic of basic goods.
Venezuela, once the richest country in Latin
America, was experiencing the worst peacetime
economic crisis in modern history.
A third of its entire economy disappeared
in one year alone — the same number as Ukraine
in 2022.
Since then, 7 million people — a quarter
of the entire population — have fled the
country.
This is the equivalent of the Great Depression,
the hyperinflation of Zimbabwe, and the Syrian
migrant crisis — all at the same time.
And it’s happening in a country with 300
billion barrels of oil.
That’s 11 times more than China and nearly
four times that of Russia, a place once referred
to as “more a gas station than a country”.
Even this understates its good fortune.
Venezuelan crude is practically begging to
be extracted.
It’s not far off-shore like Norway’s.
It’s not way up in the arctic, like Russia’s.
And it’s not deep underground, like American
shale.
Instead, it just naturally bubbles to the
surface.
And, as the Gulf States prove, one does not
need smart technocratic governance, liberal
democracy, or even remotely favorable geography.
Oil and oil alone can turn the barren Arabian
Desert into the Swiss Alps.
So, how did Venezuela go so terribly wrong?
In 2013, a staggering 96% of Venezuelan exports
were related to petroleum.
It’s not hard to see how oil prices could
make or break its economy.
Lower prices, lower revenue.
It’s very simple.
Less intuitive is the effect this has on its
currency.
You see, it’s not just about how much money
it generates.
It’s also about what kind.
When oil prices are high, there’s more demand
for Venezuela’s currency — the Bolivar
— so it appreciates.
And the more one Bolivar is worth, the fewer
you can get for the same Dollar or Euro or
Yen, making its exports more expensive for
the rest of the world.
Say, for instance, 10 Bolivars were worth
one U.S. Dollar.
At this rate, someone in Florida could buy
a pound of 20 Bolivar Venezuelan coffee for
two USD.
Not bad.
But then, oil prices cause the Bolivar to
appreciate.
That same pound of coffee now costs four U.S.
Dollars.
Through no fault of their own, coffee farmers
are now half as globally competitive.
Now, this isn’t necessarily as bad as it
sounds.
When exports are effectively twice as expensive,
imports are effectively 50% off.
Those 10 original Bolivars are worth two dollars,
not just one.
It’s no wonder virtually everything in Venezuela
is imported.
From appliances and cars to simple things
like food and apparel.
Even Bolivars themselves arrive on 747s.
All of this is to say: in Venezuela, the highs
are high.
Strong oil prices not only bring in loads
of cash, but they also make foreign goods
that much cheaper.
In 1970, Venezuela had a higher per capita
GDP than either Spain or Greece.
Nearly 60% of the population was middle-class.
And the Concorde flew direct flights to Paris.
Another explosion of wealth came during China’s
rise in the early 2000s.
As demand for oil soared, the country even
began importing doctors.
But with such high highs come extraordinarily
low lows.
Because no smart politician withholds riches
from voters, nothing is ever set aside for
a rainy day.
And in the oil business, there are always
rainy days.
Remember: When oil prices fall, the state
both loses revenue, and the imports they’ve
come to depend on become more expensive.
That’s a brutal combination.
Those coffee farmers from earlier go bankrupt
when oil prices are high, leaving Venezuela
without domestic producers of… frankly,
anything, when they aren’t.
This cycle of boom and bust has been going
on since the first well was drilled over a
hundred years ago.
But this latest crisis is especially prolonged
thanks to a potent mix of weak oil prices
and U.S. sanctions, imposed after its president
manipulated elections.
Things got so bad that the country once ran
out of money to pay its supplier of that money.
So what was the government’s solution?
Print.
More.
Money!
Since 2007, the central bank of Venezuela
is no longer independent, giving politicians
direct control of the money supply.
This, to everyone’s surprise, led to something
called “inflation”.
At first, the government simply pretended
it wasn’t happening, refusing to release
the data.
By the time it finally gave up the charade
in 2019, inflation was at 130… thousand
percent — about 129,997% higher than its
neighbor, Colombia.
While taxi drivers can easily raise their
rates to adjust for inflation, the salaries
of professionals were reduced to nothing.
No wonder such a high proportion of migrants
were doctors, lawyers, and professors.
In Venezuela, they were effectively working
for free.
And when your savings today will surely become
worthless tomorrow, there’s no reason not
to spend your paycheck immediately.
When they ran out of cash, people simply took
out loans to buy everything from TVs to plastic
surgery.
So, the government took another page out of
the “just-print-more-money” school of
economic thought — price controls.
After all, if prices are too high, why not
just impose a ceiling?
In a sense, it works: state-run supermarkets
are cheap.
Ridiculously cheap.
The question is: is there anything inside?
Because prices are set well below market rates,
shoppers are incentivized to buy as much as
they can get their hands on.
Anything you don’t need can easily be resold
for twice as much across the street or twenty
times as much across the border.
It’s estimated that up to 14% of Venezuela’s
highly-subsidized gas is smuggled internationally.
In 2015, lines outside grocery stores got
so long that everyone was assigned one day
of the week for shopping, based on the last
digit of their national ID.
To prevent the same person from using their
quota at multiple stores, fingerprint scanners
were installed at checkouts.
Soldiers even patrolled the aisles.
Here, once again, the government had a solution.
In Venezuela, there is no one exchange rate.
The value of your money depends on who you
are.
What could possibly go wrong?
To encourage companies to import essential
goods in short supply, for example, it offers
a special, favorable exchange rate.
The way it works is that a foreign company,
say a Brazilian rice producer, wants to be
paid in the global currency of trade — dollars.
For a Venezuelan company to buy and import
that rice, therefore, it has to somehow get
its hands on some USD.
That’s a problem because, until recently,
the government carefully restricted access
to foreign currency.
Unlike most countries, you couldn’t just
walk down to your neighborhood currency exchange
and trade some cash.
Huge multinational corporations like Pepsi
had to apply for the chance to exchange their
Bolivars for U.S. Dollars.
Even when these applications were accepted
— and they often weren’t — the money
might take months to arrive, making it hard
for companies to import supplies.
So few new cars entered the country, for example,
that used ones became highly prized commodities.
But, it gets worse.
The exchange rate offered by the government
wasn’t the “real” value of the Bolivar.
Meaning, the government might give you one
USD for 5 Bolivars, but nobody else would
give you a Dollar for anything less than,
say, 50.
The official exchange rate was essentially
a government handout — free money for those
smart or well-connected enough to get it.
By approving these requests for Dollars, politicians
could reward their friends and family.
By rejecting them, they could punish or silence
critics.
It also opened the door to a different, more
sophisticated, form of arbitrage.
You might ask the government for permission
to exchange 5 million Bolivars for one million
U.S. dollars to help ease the shortage of
car parts.
But instead of using that money to import
a million dollars worth of tires, you might
only import 500,000.
You could then sell the other half million
dollars on the black market for far more than
the 2.5 million Bolivars you paid.
And just like that, you’ve created money
out of thin air.
According to the government, you’re the
reason the system is broken.
“If only people bought from stores what
they needed and nothing more.
If only people stopped exchanging foreign
currency.
If only they saved and invested rather than
spending everything they have.”
At the root of Venezuela’s problems, the
government claims, are individual opportunists.
A similar argument is that the country is
plagued by a culture of selfish consumption
over prudent, long-term investment.
Voters favor politicians who promise handouts
over those with the foresight to save for
the future.
After decades of gross mismanagement, Venezuelans
have lost faith in the collective power of
the state.
But if growing the pie is an unrealistic pipe
dream, the only rational response is to fight
for your and your family’s slice.
As the world enters a period of financial
tightening and possibly even recession, today’s
sponsor, Brilliant dot org, can help us learn
from Venezuela by investing in our education
and diversifying our skill sets.
When times are tough, people invest in themselves.
After the 2008 recession, U.S. college enrollment
increased by about two and a half million.
What I love about Brilliant, the interactive
way to learn math, science, and computer science,
is that it offers the perfect balance of structure
and freedom.
I want the ability to smoothly move between
subjects — from biology to programming to
physics, for example — while being guided
through each interactive lesson.
If you’re watching this video, you’re
already a curious, self-motivated learner.
Brilliant’s lessons on topics like neural
networks, calculus, and my personal favorite,
game theory, can help you take your learning
to the next level.
Click the link on screen now or in the description
to sign up for the free 30-day trial.
The first 200 people will also get 20% off
their annual subscription.
Go, pick whatever interests you most, and
start learning today.